[Music]
hi hello everyone welcome back to the
lobby GameSpot's weekly video game
hangout here in San Francisco California
every Wednesday 11:00 a.m. Pacific I
might be Hardy here with Pete Brown
hello I was wearing a glasses for a
while before I got my eyes hurt there
yeah well the whole thing in the office
the big news in the office this week is
that Rob handler he got glasses he's not
wearing them right now though yeah I'm -
and I'm embarrassing him no you're not
it's fine I left him over there so I
don't have to wear him Kelly Plaga
usually sits there she'll be on in like
15 minutes but Aaron Sampson brought you
on for our XCOM 2 segment today I'm
definitely not Kelly because I like
talking about scum - as most people
probably know by this point we do have a
giveaway today it's a pretty dank mcpeck
giveaway though so I figured I'd save it
for later in the show it's pretty big so
I'm gonna save it for later but we do
have one so stick around the end this
show and then I will have Shiva tweeted
out and everything but I do some news
items to get through first
battlefront to beta the dates got
announced it's October 6 to 9th unless
you pre-order in which case you can jump
in 2 days earlier you'll be able to play
on Naboo
which we saw a lot of at e3 Robbie play
- Aaron you played it I think oh I snuck
into that event three or four times yeah
you guys pretty excited for this are you
gonna play the beta October 6th and 9th
that's a few days before evil within -
still like gives you time to get ready
for that October 27th does he day you
said it was Naboo again or Theed
yeah galactic assault or something or
maybe there yeah yeah I from what I
understand I was reading that briefly
there also have that everything like one
of their dedicated space battle modes oh
they're gonna have that as well okay
cool
how is that working in this game the
space battles are separate like they
were in the original battlefront - yeah
but I feel like they're kind of ramping
them up a little bit more they have like
you know each side has like a capital
ship that you're trying to destroy and I
think one of the major gripes of the
last one is that like when you when
you're doing those I fear what they call
them just Fighter Squadron actually that
you know there isn't much to it there's
there's oftentimes nothing in the map to
like utilize as far as like cover or
obstacles mm-hmm so I think they were
stressing that they're gonna have like
asteroid fields and you know means to
like maneuver through and you know get
get the guy on your six off cool yeah we
got a lot of stuff from e3 about like
the same map and everything so you guys
can go check that out
we talked extensively about it we had an
interview with devs that came on a
couple of producers from the title as
well in other good news I think it's
like a third week in a row I've been
talking about a really successful
fundraiser stream summer games done
quick raise 1.7 million this year the
biggest donation was twenty thousand
three hundred dollars I don't it might
have been anonymous I didn't apologize I
didn't look yeah Pete Brown donated over
20 grand but no whoever that was that
was awesome and I think they beat their
last year's total by like half a mil or
something man something like that uh
yeah so good news after that destiny The
Guardian stream that happened recently
also raised a ton of money so good on
them
spider-man Home Coming which I still
have not seen and I really want to but
uh it got 117 million opening weekend
over here and which still behind
spider-man 3 which apparently did 170 if
I'm remembering that correctly mmm dang
yeah so that's doing pretty well it's
Tom Hollands first standalone movie he
made the I think it's know by now it's
not a spoiler he was in the Civil War
briefly Captain America Civil War he
stole the show on that one yeah
who's good I really wanna see this a
shame that it didn't make as much as
spider-man 3 which is like the worst
movie ever made
it's yeah 2007 in spider-man 3 made a
151 million so it's been doing really
well but yeah that 117 was just in the
u.s. it was really great I really like
this movies oh you did see it yeah I'm
sorry yeah you liked it I very much did
I think is definitely the best
spider-man um as far as the other ones
go
so the what five other ones I guess
three Tobey Maguire's to Andrew Garfield
yeah yeah live-action at least in last
all right yeah I was laughing like the
humor was like top-notch there was a
really good episode of lazer times a
podcast one mention real quick where
Henry Gilbert broke down sort of the
long road of getting spider-man to film
and how Marvel sort of mishandled a lot
of its properties back when I was going
through like these like waves of
bankruptcy and stuff
really really interesting stuff like
spider-man got passed around for like
almost nothing and was squandered left
and right easy a pre interesting
look at that yeah I saw what they had to
sell it to Sony or something like that
is that yes sort of and James Bond was
even part of the bartering for
spider-man in a weird way yeah cool
Bertha listen and I guess Michael Keaton
played a really good vulture am i mixing
those that up
no that's the second time he's played a
Birdman
cool so I mean that's good news I like a
lot of people kind of burnt out on
Marvel movies or I mean superhero movies
in general so I'm looking forward to
seeing that we are going to talk sort of
more video game related than that we're
gonna talk about the Castlevania Netflix
series like whatever mini series
whatever it is in a little bit we're
gonna get to XCOM to going to get to
what else we're doing a final fantasy 12
the zodiac age released yesterday the
remaster which everybody was clamoring
about splatoon two single-player we
can't talk about the entire game we'll
get to that later
Kali's reviewing it her review will be
up next week we could talk fully about
it a week from today but yeah we'll be
getting into a few big game say but one
last news item an apology John Luke I'm
kind of thrown and set you last second
but I forgot that few of us forgot we
came in the office today destiny two's
beta is coming soon I have a bunch of
dates right here so destiny to ps4 beta
early access start time is July 18th
10:00 a.m. Pacific for those who
pre-order so that's how you get early
access
same thing with battlefront and a lot of
other games Xbox one will be July 19th
for those who pre-order at 10:00 a.m.
destiny to open beta start time for all
players in all consoles if you didn't
just pre-order his July 21st at 10 a.m.
Pacific man those are a lot of dates
wait what's this July 23rd 108 ends on
July 23rd and then what the last Sunday
you get like an hour in the social space
so they could stress test it yeah you
can go walk around the farm
talk to some of it the new people will
play some soccer party yes sweet cool no
PC then huh I guess that's not much of a
surprise right since that it is it not
or is that just consoles does that mean
oh sorry PC
yeah PC beta star time is sometime in
August some more to follow
we don't know exactly yeah stay tuned
for the giveaway it later on the show
good segue cool let's get to the show
XCOM to war the chosen expansions coming
August 29th same day as Mario Plus
rabbits Kingdom battle but yeah XCOM 2
is not right game I mean no I just
kidding Mario my favorite games ever
we're the chosen expansion it is war
that shows and that shows more right I'm
saying that correctly yes there are
there are chosen people hunting you down
sweet
so you and Miguel our editor got to go
up to Novato to to Kay's office hang out
with some Firaxis folks and play the
expansion ahead of time or at least a
little bit of it they give you kind of a
few tidbits from it that's gonna be out
in August later this summer but it's
super interesting because Jake Salomon
we brought him under stage show at e3
and he was saying like it's even bigger
than an enemy within and I think kind of
uh I think Eurogamer did like a hundred
twelve new things in this expansion and
I watched through it it's nuts it's I
mean it's a long list videos like 20
minutes but it's worth watching if you
are super interested in all the nitty
gritty details but you actually got
hands-on time you and Miguel you got to
try out a couple of new units so I don't
want to I want to talk to you like broad
strokes what is this changing from the
base game that all of us loved so much
yeah so war the chosen adds three new
playable classes the reaper skirmisher
and templar we got to play the Reaper
and the skirmisher then there's three
chosen on the Advent side of things who
are basically hunting the commander
while you're playing these new classes
and they are like the it's assassin a
warlock and there's one other sniper
character I'll have to look at the name
but the interesting thing about that is
it's there like three boss battles that
you're essentially doing throughout the
game so they will appear early in the
game when you cannot kill them and
they'll try and abduct characters or
interrogate characters of yours and then
you'll fight them they'll disappear and
they'll grow in strength over time so
they're actually growing as your
characters are growing and your
motivation is actually if you kill these
chosen characters you get their weapons
which is really cool I know those
previous x-column DLC where you would
fight like
snake or like a giant behemoth alien
hunters da yeah
alien hunters um but I don't believe you
got to keep anything out of that
experience and not that I remember it
was more of a kind of just side bounty
experience money
yeah the quest yeah so these multistage
boss battles will actually net you
really high level epic weapons and when
you finish them it's super interesting
though right yeah yeah well yeah cuz
they're saying like they'll start
apparently they were like Miguel talks
in and they said they'll start adapting
to how you play I think it was the was
it the assassin she it has like a sniper
rifle but she can also get up close kind
of like almost like a I don't know a
ranger the sniper rifle but she will
start adapting to how you play and Jake
Sam was saying it's super inspired by
the Nemesis system from shadow of Mordor
because he thought you know you're
you're getting into the like your head
Canon with your own characters but now
this kind of grants that that you know
that kind of rivalry with the enemy more
because you're actually getting to know
these enemies did you get a sense of
that at all I mean you only play it for
a couple hours right yeah they do the
fan like XCOM in general does a
fantastic job of making you really care
about characters just through like
little bits of dialogue and in short
cutscenes in a way that I think a lot of
other games miss so we saw the assassin
and when they introduced her she has a
sister the hunter who like they hate
each other
mhm mhm actually like all of the chosen
kind of don't really like each other you
could see how the advent probably built
them through like adversarial
competition so like you get a sense of
who these people are right away the
Warlock is a zealot he's like super
sipping the kool-aid and he doesn't like
the fact that the two sister true chosen
sisters are fighting each other all the
time
you supposed to get down to business on
on the XCOM side the the Reaper and the
skirmisher also don't trust each other
like the skirmisher right they're stuck
in the doorway whose game place it's not
mine but that's that's the skirmisher
yeah I do want to talk about those units
as well and then I want to get into the
bond system which seems pretty cool this
is the loss right here these zombies
were to being introduced I'm sorry I'm
jumping the gun I'm excited about this
yes so the
/ and the skirmisher they've showed off
trailers for on their YouTube channel
which I think we post on our site as
well and then they've also shown the
assassin and the Warlock enemies kind of
showing them all before we get to August
29th we had a scripture right here is
the one I'm pretty interested in because
it seems like a kind of one-person squad
almost rolled into a one soldier yeah
the I think his high level game is to
basically like generate turns mm-hmm
repeated turns at the low level what we
saw was his base loadout which like his
more unique ability although it's a
little bit like that I think the spider
suit from XCOM he has a grappling hook
that can hook him to places but he can
also grab enemies and pull them towards
him which is a kind of a big deal
because if you're being mind-controlled
by sectoid and you need to get you need
to get the sectoid into your team like
in your groups you can kill it or like
some enemies you just want to pull out
of position to screw with their their
ability to mess with your team although
you have to be careful in usual Dexcom
fashion learning through trial and error
I pulled in an inferno unit and then
shot it and it blew up in my character's
face and kill them instantly well saying
sure like you didn't shoot it you
wolverine clawed it right yeah yeah that
was pretty funny to watch damn but yeah
that's that emerging kind of stuff that
you might not expect that unless you
play for a while
mhm and the interesting thing is again
like XCOM does great storytelling the
inferno unit isn't there for no reason
they're there to deal with the lost
which are the zombies so they're zombies
will attack anybody in the game and the
Advent have to deal with them also which
is just a whole another edit strategy
layer it's like the the flood and halo
it's a third faction actually a lot of
shooters have that trope there's like
the lambent and Gears of War it
introduces a third faction so it's not
just one on one the whole time and then
yeah actually the one thing we're kind
of seeing here whether you realize or
not is the bond system which Jake
saamana said was a little bit inspired
by Fire Emblem which X come through the
base game and XCOM and XCOM enemy within
didn't really have these relationships
like if sometimes if one soldier died
right next to a rookie they'd panic and
start running around or something or
just not like they'd freeze up but now
there's actually like these
relationships of form between two
specific so
you got to see a load of that right yeah
we kept asking about it as like a
romance system they were kind of
laughing about that because I think it's
a little bit lighter than you know like
a full-on
massive yet they're not gonna end up in
a shower somewhere hey love Campbell
you're solid yeah
but yeah the bond systems interesting
again like you already care about your
characters next come just through the
stories you tell yourself and having two
characters who like you know are
basically in love with each other
makes it that much more meaningful they
get stat bonuses if they stay next to
each other and they also can do things
like the Reaper or sorry the scrim sure
got kidnapped in our game by the
assassin mm-hmm in a subsequent mission
we had to go rescue him and I did that
classic mistake where you Jam somebody
in a doorway and they run out of turns
yeah and you're just hosed mm-hmm so
early on in the bond system if your bond
mate is there they can actually just
give you an extra turn
do you like hey get the hell out of that
doorway I need to go rescue this dude
you played enough XCOM you know it's a
huge deal to get an extra action getting
that aura yeah
that doorway GM can be life and death if
you make that mistake yeah and then also
the you know converse side of it if one
of them dies the other can react really
negatively on yeah that's what's gonna
ask if there's a big detriment like to
losing one of those yeah I'm characters
through I think their bond mate being
killed or even your regular soldiers now
through losing multiple rounds can start
to accumulate negative traits like new
negative traits that are that aren't
generated when they're first there they
just fart a lot yeah flatulence like
bezerk right herb didn't Miguel say he
heard that or something cuz urk like
they don't obey orders
they're just get pissed off or like
maybe we have a last stand kind of my
life isn't worth it at all but I'm
wondering like you know if you get
severely injured in a mission you get a
few days downtime for you know like
healing an R&R on the Avenger I'm
wondering if that would happen - I
imagine they wouldn't just bounce back
right after the mission yes I think
there's more downtime for soldiers who
lose a couple of missions encountering
that there's a new sort of bonus system
with the new factions it was just done
in the menus but you get to
depending on the new factions you get to
pick some bonuses mm-hmm that sort of
counteract some of that and also
counteract the feel like negative
mystery events that the Advent throw at
you on it on like every month as well
right so there's a couple a couple new
systems in light em like that in the
game that make it a little bit more
challenging mm-hmm but I think in
general XCOM 2 was designed to be
tougher with a longer tail for like
higher level players yeah I mean I was I
was I played a lot of enemy within and
enemy Unknown but I still started on
rookie in this game just because it was
pretty tough there are there a lot of
parts like if it's your first time
playing it you're expected to die for
the most part but I've got a friend who
beat Ironman impossible on the first
game which is the most like a misnomer
because obviously it's not impossible
but I'm curious to see how this will
shape the difficulty but I'm really
looking forward to this give any last
thoughts on the expansion which comes
out later this summer before we kick you
off I'm honestly envious of anybody who
maybe didn't play a lot of XCOM - mhm
and it's coming back now with all the
DLC in the expansions and you know enemy
within was the same same kind of thing
he's one of those games that's almost
good if you haven't played too much of
it because now you're getting the full I
think vision of what that game can be
all those sort of stuff like on the
battlefield that extends to the main
XCOM - game yeah okay yeah yeah it's a
full expansion not just DLC so you'll
get I'm assuming if you get this you'll
also get gens last gift which gets you
the robots energies children which is
more aesthetic stuff which it doesn't
matter as much because this game has a
really really fleshed out modding
community which we had a really
interesting conversation would take
Solomon on our lobby stage at the show
about like what role dude does DLC or an
expansion play in a game that like long
war is the biggest mod I can imagine
that's like a full expansion in itself
and I really that's how I prefer to play
game now is long war I don't you check
tit out for the second game yet she
makes it really hard there's like six
more soldier classes you have to
micromanage every little thing down to
their like specific weapon attachments
and I don't know everything but it's
interesting that this is yeah this is
kind of like enemy within but it's even
bigger because it's you know revamping
the base game so I mean I imagine they
might do like an actual separate retail
copy
they did with enemy within mm-hmm to get
for PlayStation 4 Xbox one and PC and
everything I'll probably play this on PC
but yeah cool that's August 29th again
later in the summer same day as Mario
Plus Rabbids which is like Jake Solomon
head was say it was pretty funny to
watch during the Ubisoft conference city
was really surreal but yeah anyway cool
he wasn't the one crying in that
conference though no that was the yeah
the director was he Italian the area was
in Milan the spot I don't remember
sorry cool Aaron thanks so much for
coming on and you'll have are we gonna
have like some other video about the
Spanish like a list like an easier
digestible thing yeah watch we're
putting up to 2 gameplay Clips today
one's gonna be a cutscene of the chosen
and one's gonna be the zombies as you
guys can see we showed some of that here
and then we'll work on maybe good list
video for you guys of how that game
feels and sort of what changes are
coming to it sweet sweet thank you so
much Aaron talk to you later
count me out yeah come on man we're
gonna bring the real Cali play on we
watched I watched Castlevania last night
finally I guess yeah it's been out a
week yeah you've been telling me you
liked it I liked it but it's a it's a
real roller coaster I don't I don't like
it it kind of sucks yeah if you if you
really like examine it and want to be
analytical about it it sucks I don't
like most anime but it's fun to watch
yeah you're trying to rile us I'm trying
to rile Kali up just getting energy into
this thing Kali flag it what's up hi
even playing splatoon too and whatnot
mm-hmm did you watch Castlevania I did I
figured you would cuz your anime expert
so that's that's the question for people
who haven't watched it yet Castlevania
is like four or what 23 minute episodes
yes I sleep yeah and I watched it last
night I got bored like really what yeah
that was no ring dude I'm gonna be I'm
gonna be honest I haven't watched the
fourth episode because I got portion the
fourth episode
yeah the fourth episode was the one I
wasn't bored during I would say I'm
gonna watch it but last night I
literally I was watching it and I was
like I should clean my room and I
to the three episode I just stopped
watching it I was doing too well I
immediately liked the art style itself
threw me off it's so stiff and yeah and
I couldn't like just literally the act
of looking at it was kind of arduous for
me yeah well in Bryant it I had my TV
was like facing the other way so I had
to like put a mirror on it no I'm just
kidding but it literally it really does
have moments though that are striking
compositions also yeah I was gonna say
like yes you're right on the like the
stiff animation but like some of the
just like I mean I visuals are just like
pretty engaging or at least for me while
we're looking at it now I just want to
say I love this intro' like I think the
intro was really stunning mm-hmm
but they're there the quality is
inconsistent with the animations Jason
dunk on the YouTube chat said boring are
you effing serious yeah I was pretty
boring during the show it's me and Rob
were talking and I think one of the
strengths of the show is the pacing of
it all like it does it in four episodes
they accomplish quite a bit like you if
you really take stock of it all it's I
don't know I I'm surprised to hear you
guys are bored yeah like it moved around
quick enough where I wasn't bored as far
as like scenes go you know ii mean like
like scenes moved fairly quickly for i
mean to me at least right they kept me
engaged like yeah i don't swallow
anything actually but yeah it's actually
there's not much to spoil no that's just
it it's pretty devoid of like really
interesting story things it borrows a
lot from Castlevania 3 and that is the
basis for the show
and it basically is just building up to
reveal a character which isn't the
secret he's in the intro well there's
really nothing and it's the use you know
if you didn't play the games I don't
think they really they don't mention his
name in the intro either nobody's that
one prominent character that you don't
see up until that point sure Castlevania
3 was the first one where Trevor bellman
was the playable character right Victor
was Trevor is from a different time line
well not different times it is cursive
Dracula Castlevania 3 curse of darkness
Chris darkness no he if I'm correct
Trevor was
the in near of feet I think that was his
first no no no no his first one was
lords of shadow he was the so all three
of those the cast the lords of shadow
games was Trevor Belmont wasn't ha
yeah then there wasn't it was my
Wikipedia this last night was a favor
was a different different character for
sure okay but Trevor's first appearance
or at least first playable appearance
was Cassidy right that was somebody else
anyway anyway I really liked the series
obviously my memories shoddy but there
was a lot of fanservice in this I guess
it the best compliment I can give it is
it made me really really want to play
like symphony soon again as in like
later this week you're not gonna play it
I'm super get playing talking about
playing that game flippin once I've been
talking about playing Final Fantasy
Tactics for month but like Symphony I
have played numerous times before but
okay anyway I think so just to go back
on the point where I got bored at the
end of the third episode because I was
like I think the reason is because it's
only four episodes and I was like I
don't I kind of want them to make more
it almost feels like this was a test and
they were like all right let's see if
people don't hate it
mm-hmm and I don't hate it like I want
to be clear like I there's a lot I like
about it I think the gore is actually
super cool you don't see that in a lot
of animation it's insane this is my life
right here people get visser ated and
you don't see that in animation a lot so
there's a lot to like about it I just
felt like alright that was the teaser to
the real series almost and I know
there's gonna be a second season I will
continue to watch it I just didn't feel
the need to finish it like right then
and there I had other stuff to do kind
of thing it did feel have they mentioned
like when it might release the second
series is it gonna be a while because I
mean if they give it a normal year that
they give series this is gonna I'm gonna
completely forget about everything that
happened and then it's pretty sure they
said 2018 but I think Callie's point
makes sense like they're probably
producing it right now I'm sure they had
a story and script ready to go they've
had it's a pile over court so yeah pilot
season so many of these shows are like
that right like yeah yeah you even think
about
Ranger things like I think didn't that
pilot or show premise get passed around
from like Studio to studio before it
finally landed at Netflix I think those
guys had a tough time and I don't know
they probably said yeah give us you know
what eight episodes and we'll see yeah
I'm wondering how much of my initial
excitement for this which is because so
many video game adaptations are really
shitty but I don't know I like I said it
makes me want to play catch me but I
just thought it was kind of dumb it is
dumb but not nothing like I'm not in a
good dumb way I actually thought it was
like I don't know like I felt like it
was written by what Warren Ellis who has
done really good graphic novels or comic
books right both I'm not familiar with
him necessarily but I mean it just felt
like so many I was watching I was like
why did they just cut away from that
scene right now and I'm not not even in
like a really covertly critical
cinematography kind of aspect just I
really felt like every time it got
interesting they want to do something
else there on that point there's one cut
in the third episode that reminded me so
much of Avatar The Last Airbender
because it was just like this comedic
beat and I loved it like there's stuff
like that that I really like I think
it's I think it's good dumb when it is
dumb I think like the banter equips or
like I like that part of the show like
that bar scene the part is like I think
it's a third episode so I'm kind of
intrigued but yeah like the bar scene
was just so it remind me of like a game
of Thrones moment that was even like
almost a satire on that right yeah like
drunkards having like an argument
I found it talking about their balls or
whatever yeah it was so dumb I enjoyed
it yeah I'm I liked the voice acting a
lot like three people from The Hobbit
we're in it Thorin Oakenshield I forget
his name he was a voice actor for Trevor
the dude who played Dwalin was also in
it Thor that name checks a court I think
he did that the bunker was he that
live-action what do you call that
like live-action game that would
pointing click what's the name of that
stuff her story
bumped active yeah yeah yeah that is not
the same dude I don't think oh that name
sounds familiar
either way so Kelly and Pete the first
thing that we you guys brought up when
we were talking about talking about this
was how a lot of people are calling it
anime but is that just that should I
just at a glance that's what he was
saying for being like vaguely
reminiscent of some Japanese cartoon
yeah I wouldn't consider it anime I
think that's a nebulous term in and of
itself yeah of course it is short for
animation so like you're gonna run into
weird ambiguities of what the definition
of anime is I mean it's literally the
Japanese word for animation yeah you
know and like there was even a Hideki
Nagano when I believe that an old Sega
composer was like wait this cartoon
isn't anime like he was confused because
to him it's like anything that's a
cartoon is an anime it's animated right
so there's no right answer here it's
just yeah but like as far as I think
it's something that like seems like
anime to I guess the somebody who
doesn't watch a lot of anime but it's
really hard to describe you feel like
you have to have this body of knowledge
of different kinds of animation to be
able to discern yeah because there's
really no one set definition like some
people define anime as things that were
made by Japanese studios and that is
difficult in its own way because like
Avatar The Last Airbender wouldn't call
anime but and Japanese animation studios
did work on the end of the same thing
with JRPG it's it's this silly way that
we categorize and and this is only
related to Japan their media as it
really as we consume it right we're
never we're not talking about like
Ukranian animation differently or
Ukrainian RPGs differently right for
some reason people who love media and
entertainment love to do this to
Japanese things yeah it's meaningless
but also this is not animate the people
had been asking we do have a question a
couple questions actually on Twitter but
Grant Wilson he was wondering will the
popularity of the Netflix series bring
about a new game perhaps on the switch
will they ever revisit lords of shadow
well first of all mercury steam who did
the lords of shadow mirror fate they're
doing samus returns which is almost out
mid September 17th or something maybe
the lords of shadow games and mirrors
all three of them all three okay gotcha
um by the way Trevor Belmont was the
protagonist of Castlevania three we
already established that I just wanted
you to know that I was right about an
older game
I can't wait to argue with you after the
show okay
[Music]
what alright so anyway um do you think
there'll be another Castlevania game
after this like does this bode well for
the series in general for the franchise
if people want to play new Castlevania
game play blood-stained ritual of the
night
that's Kody garages game what people
think of most people who was the creator
of Castlevania for those who know he's
not a creative counseling he's not but
he did Symphony night right yeah he also
gave up a career right it helped write
this for those who don't know who
Igarashi is what's his involvement with
it he's making a game that's basically
Symphony of the Night and 2.5 D that's
his mission he stated I'm making the
sort of games like I used to at the
company I used to work for so look
forward to that so mm-hmm you can play
those games I don't think you're gonna
see another game like lords of Shadow
because again mercury steam is sort of
out of that business we might see new
Castlevania game but probably not one
I'd want to play like I don't know I
don't know if the success I mean to
answer the question like I don't think
the success of this show would
necessarily warrant another like I don't
know there's ego I don't know if those
are like one-to-one you know what I mean
mm-hm yeah yeah I think Konami is
certainly trying their hand at a lot of
different things right now so like
there's their diverse company anyway
they make a lot of their money on like
fitness equipment in Japan so maybe
they'll just rest on their laurels and
say Castlevania is an entertainment
property okay cuz that's a game I don't
know it's hard to know what the series
has left to say mm-hmm yeah
why is it that were excited for like
Metroid is because we haven't seen a
good Metroid since like the primes is
that yeah yes sure Metroid has been off
neglected right I would argue we would
haven't seen a good Castlevania I didn't
really like lords of Shadow I thought
the first one was pretty good but
they're not Castlevania I mean that's
the thing is like we're calling them
Castlevania games but they're so
different I mean you really need to come
with I'm sure you had the right
expectations but like I can't even I
thought we were talking about them in
the same breath yeah I was gonna say
like the lords of Shadow games are much
more different from the older style of
Castlevania games
like Metroid Prime trilogy is from
Metroid games because metroid prime is
actually still maintains a similar
structure it's just 3d yeah yeah
lords of shadow were actually like
linear Devil May Cry kind of God of War
third-person action character games but
it's also we got like the The Witcher
Netflix series coming out which would be
live-action everything right which
obviously like that was in development
now or that was in production you know
like probably like before Castlevania or
at least simultaneously it's not like
this spark it's not like a subpoena
sparked this original fad right it's
been in the works for like 10 years or
something we have an article about it on
Castlevania has been in the works 10
years yeah
according to micro Joe our new
entertainment editor you should check
out the article damn 10 years as well
yeah that's like almost a decade that's
close yeah that is actually I'm excited
for The Witcher I saw the author was
saying that he's excited for the
characters to finally be done justice
because he's not a fan of the video
games yeah what you know like if you
played the games you know or at least
I've played 2 & 3 and I thought they
were pretty great in terms of
characterization but man CG for that
series is gonna make or break it for me
like I feel like that's so much of a
budget you know I mean and like if you
don't like pay attention to it I don't
know like you just I would like dismiss
it you know I mean like yeah it's like
you almost need a game of Thrones like
budget for like certain things in though
in that series yeah I do that I think
Game of Thrones for the most part they
they'll time they're CG nicely or
they'll go all out for that brief like I
don't know if feels like maybe 30
seconds per episode like if that yeah
but you think about The Witcher I mean I
feel like I mean for the games like half
of the experiences like slaying monsters
like but but there's also a lot of
really interesting environmental stuff
that's really dark and kind of
otherworldly like that's a great
opportunity for practical effects I
think and like yeah the sexy stuff yeah
there's the sexy stuff the unicorn the
unicorn better
all right so Castlevania Netflix was for
20 minute episodes you can go watch
right now I guess let me know what you
think cuz I didn't really like it but no
I'm excited I'm excited for more I think
I think it got you liked it we were
excited for ya cuz I think it got good
right as it ended but of course like you
guys said it like to your point it was
like a more pilot and it kind of proof
of concept I guess in a way even though
you know I think I think our
expectations are just a little bit lower
because it's a video game adaptation
yeah what's the next one
sorry to cut you off for using oh just
gonna say as far as video game
adaptations go I really liked it and I
liked it in general yeah it was brief
alright well what's next Assassin's
Creed right yes a discreet as I'd like
confirmed confirmed like in the works
pretty sure should be I feel like it was
estimated for 2018 but I could be wrong
on that but I'm pretty sure that's in
the works okay like we don't know that
much about it's like oh it's in the
Assassin's Creed universe and it's
featuring an original story what is that
even takes place in 2675 it's an
assassin's creed story and then you see
desmond no it doesn't music gonna die
almost all right enough of Assassin's
Creed spoilers ah we also have been
playing final fantasy 12 zodiac Age well
but yeah remaster
Miguel yeah Miguel concepcion reviewed
it gave it a 9 out of 10 it's a remaster
of the about 2000 ps2 game my name of a
good movie that's the name of a good
movie that hasn't been made yet
[Laughter]
movie or porno Portman just like Papa
Roach playing in time we you played a
little bit of it and this was you said
you only played a couple of hours back
in the original these are decades kind
of exciting for you what makes this game
interesting from what I understand you
can animate the entire earth sorry
automate the entire game
it's so cool it's like programming like
you could write your scripts for it like
this is the coolest thing because I've
never played a Final Fantasy and I find
this just super interesting on the basis
of like oh my god you can write like a
recurring script for your NPCs and
that's just like the nerdiest thing I
could say about it is yeah and it's for
you it's for me yeah so combat
specifically yeah but then you can also
issue commands if you want yeah but it's
a hybrid like you can grind that way
like I feel like it can help take away
the grinding they added four times speed
so if you automate if you write your
scripts correctly you could pretty much
grind without having to do anything you
could do something else which is so cool
if you oh like you script an account for
a four time speed just a setting but you
should write characters react battle
scripts seriously like if there's oh if
this then he'll my gotten yeah I guess
to be clear it's like it kind of like
if-then sort of statements if you're
familiar with like programming it all
but like um that's cool
yeah I think it's really really cool but
if you don't like grinding I actually do
like grinding so I don't know how much I
would use it but it takes that away
essentially which is really cool uh
what's going on in this story that's
appears the game played like a first
couple hours like a few times but
essentially there's two major warring
countries and there's two smaller
countries sort of caught in the middle
and they're trying to negotiate where
they fall you know on that side of the
battle and some people get frames and so
your party is sort of there that's
trying to like I think fix the war for
the two smaller nations and simply get
out unscathed and they represent royalty
they represent you know military
generals commoners look stuff like that
it's a good good mix I have been told
that the characters are very Star Wars
asking yeah there's a there's a lot of
sort of Star Wars II tropes going on
here I'm cool this is the Star Wars of
Final Fantasies yeah yeah like what like
what like characters like there's a luke
parallel and off
parallel right aren't they just Jesus
parallels well sure I mean but okay
here's here's my major question what
does it say about a game that there are
so many ways you can just not play it
like automating I mean I know that's
super reductive and playing devil's
advocate why would I want to get into a
game that I I it's fun because I am NOT
actually actively involved with it I
mean that is a very good question I
think the appeal for me knowing that and
not necessarily loving it is that it
sort of made by a team that made a lot
of very interesting pivots for Final
Fantasy and I'd like what they've done
in a lot of ways also outside of the
series so I know there's a body of work
that has sort of influenced this and I
and I'm and I really just want to see
where it goes because I really like the
body of work that came before it from
the people involved yeah for me I think
the coolest thing about writing scripts
is watching them successfully execute so
like even if I don't have my hands on
the controller like knowing that I wrote
the right combination of scripts is
really satisfying to me um but I feel
like that is a weird mindset that not a
lot of people would have I just really
liked the computer science that I did
study so I'm excited that I like can
apply it to my actual job instead of
forgetting about it I don't know by the
sound of like talking to Miguel the game
will introduce like really unforeseen
difficult enemies that will force you to
rethink how you are setting up your
party and what they can do in combat so
it's it's you know it's one of those
things that sounds like you have to
constantly manage and rethink it's not
like you find one solution that you put
in just sort of rest on that for a while
right there's also classes involved with
characters you know these so you have to
mix to that there's different skill sets
as well some of the traditional like
Final Fantasy jobs are here a like some
untraditional yeah what uh have you seen
any interesting ones yet no so I still I
really haven't played that much and one
of the things that this game is that it
takes hours just sort of get
to the whole well you unlock a job
pretty early but it takes hours to get
to the point where you're actually
seeing what those jobs can do and dozens
of hours before you can get a second job
and really start to you know create
multi-purpose characters how long is
this game typically hundred hours yeah I
just played I'm almost I'm sad knowing
I'm almost done with persona 5 and I
know it for a fact this time well I
think I'm right before the final boss
and just clearing up some stuff in
mementos
but yeah I'm interested like are there
any what other there any major changes
we haven't covered that this does to the
original game one of the things that has
is this thing called the License Board
which is another sort of like odd design
decision that people are still kind of
trying to grapple with where you sort of
you move along this like checkerboard
with these you know squares that touch
each other and you unlock the ability to
equip certain pieces of equipment or you
know use certain abilities it's a it's a
like you can't just go like for example
get an item and automatically use it you
have to like get to that place on the
board for your character okay in the
original game everyone sort of shared a
very similar board so you would end up
making characters that were pretty
similar but in this game the boards are
different in the way that they're shared
is different so you end up being forced
to actually make characters that are
kind of distinct from one another but
apparently that is also optional you can
go back to the old system if you want to
I think Miguel is telling me that yeah
from my understanding it adds things
that were in a Japanese only special
edition of the original game yeah the
international version so for anybody who
played the US version it's going to have
those features that you didn't have the
first time around it was also cool like
if you're a really big final fantasy fan
a really big fan of the game like
getting to check out the definitive
version that we didn't get originally
it's kind of cool - was this the Final
Fantasy game where the main like
creative director left halfway through
and someone else had to come on and fill
in form sort of so yeah yes to me
Monsuno was a guy behind NASA tactics
vagrant story over battle tactics over a
lot of good [ __ ] he left partway through
development due to health reasons which
in Japan can mean a lot of different
things and we're really knows
what the deal was and apparently the
vision for the game remained the same I
think it was a recent interview Jeremy
parish did where he was speaking to the
guy who kind of took over the reigns of
course Hironobu Sakaguchi was involved
in this game as well so it was always
sort of being watched over by like you
know the old Final Fantasy hands yeah
but yeah there was some turmoil
development it was delayed for a while
and it's one of those things that I
think has I want to say tainted but as
colored Matsu knows reputation in a way
cuz like this was he was made he made a
lot of really interesting small games
and was given like a huge you're making
a main line Final Fantasy and it he
couldn't do it and he hasn't really had
a major project that's that's caught
fire since which is a bit unfortunate
interesting
you know I have the game I just bought
it yesterday I would like to get to it I
want to and maybe maybe I will like it
this in this time in place because of
the automated stuff maybe that'll
actually appeal to me because I just got
through a hundred hour RPG but yeah
looking forward to checking it out fast
forward four times yeah you kept me you
could be like playing Zelda on the
switch while this is happening just kill
two birds with one I don't know that
fast forward stuff I know that like it
makes sense for someone like replaying
the game definitely but like obviously
to be fair I'm not gonna be as invested
in what's happening on his screen
because I didn't do all the if then
sequencing and everything he's gonna be
knowing what's going on and have a
better understanding and getting more
out of it but it does seem a little bit
weird when I see it it's very funny to
watch him with like the controller just
like the DualShock just on his desk he's
like typing something I can't press X
like but yeah like you said I mean he
knows what's going on better than the
rest of us do but the I think the choke
about running in for time speed is
ridiculous the most I played of any
Final Fantasy still is like two hours of
15 I don't know if like 12 I would you
even I don't want talk about tactics
never mind um all right cool any last
thoughts on final fantasy 12 to zodiac
age are you gonna play more of it this
week you think yeah I think I think so
like
things are a little bit quiet right now
so I'm cooking bandage that and play a
game that will not be up for game of the
year so I start to play persona in here
no I'm saying twelve because we don't do
remasters okay I thought you're just
insulting it no I said you seemed semi
positive about it
cool Kali Pete Rob actually you've all
played a little bit splatoon - Kellie
you play a lot P played decent amount
mm-hmm we can't talk about the entire
game today apologies the review will be
up Tuesday July 18th but we can talk
about the single-player
in this here sequel from Nintendo Kali
initial thoughts about single-player we
can only talk up to like the third world
or something little over half yes yeah
my so I played a descent amount of the
original splatoon I think in that game
single-player I mean it was a little
kind of tacked on last minute not last
minute but it didn't feel as complete as
this does it feels like a really great
introduction to the mechanics lots of
smart level design that makes good use
of weapons and splatoon's unique
movement and I think one of the coolest
things about splatoon as a shooter is
the movement and so I really really
liked that they took the time to really
implement that and you can use all the
different weapons in single-player as
opposed to the first game where it was
just the splatter shot so a good
opportunity to use you know like the
bucket against moving targets instead of
just practicing at the store as you
wouldn't the original splatoon so I
really enjoy it it's really fun that
collectables are smart there's a lot to
like about it
yeah I mean like I didn't even play much
of the first game but watching the
single-player it looks appealing
obviously mechanically this game is
super interesting for what it does with
a shooter genre but Rob you were saying
it feels kind of like compartmentalized
like you were wondering if well we can't
talk about past the third world but from
your perspective on the first few worlds
you said it felt like they were
introducing ideas before they went on to
someone else something else but when it
got interesting yeah I felt like I mean
I guess you'd call these stages or
levels but like here right it's just
this kind of like you know sunset
overdrive like
just rails it's awesome and that thing
this is really rad right and Clank
almost 2 and I wanted more of this in
the respect that like you move on to a
you know in another stage and it's
something completely different a new
system or mechanic and I guess what I'm
hoping is that I mean again I've only
played like an hour and a half I'm
hoping that you know eventually these
these levels will accumulate all these
different things right and so you're
doing a bunch of different stuff you're
hopefully utilizing or you know seeing a
rail or seeing these different systems
and play and experimenting and kind of
you know diversifying to your own way
you know like like how so in that hour
and a half how far have you gotten
are you I mean cuz it's very new there's
like those overworld right so I I just
like hit up probably six or seven of
these levels okay yeah so one I mean
those levels in ER get introduced in the
second world and and then the third that
are remix in the ideas that you learn
great yeah but you're discussing oh yeah
I think like like I said I think it's
really really smart so it's a great way
to get you used to DIF like the unique
kinds of movement and shooting and
attacking that you're gonna be doing
hopefully in multiplayer and I'm really
excited like it got me more excited for
multiplayer because I feel adequately
prepared like I feel like oh I got a
great introduction to different weapons
I know which weapons I like I feel
completely competent when I'm using them
I'm excited to try them out in a
different environment and figure out
more strategies with those weapons
speaking of weapons this like laser or
like sniper rifle gun I don't know
railgun thank you that's better word
it's awesome I I tried out a bunch of
them and I kept falling back to this
thing just thinking about it you know
because you just you're basically
creating a guaranteed lane right and
there's so much of this game is based on
you know being a squid or whatever yeah
exactly like it's it's really smart the
way the level encourages you to use the
weapons not just for damage but also for
like you know you create a line of ink
in front of you you can easily get out
of a tricky situation the charger is
also really cool because they changed it
up a little bit so from the previous
game now you can hold the charge while
you're under the ink for a very short
period of time which is it increases the
the
threat that you pose when you're when
you're sniping so it's really cool for
the first three worlds how about how
long can you talk about how long the
single-player campaign is likely to be
once we can talk about the full thing
that's a good question sorry console how
apology if I'm butchering that and the
YouTube chat was asking its
each level is probably between five and
ten minutes
yeah it depends on you know how obsessed
you are with getting collectibles like
I've done sure I've done like 20 minute
runs like hunting stuff down yeah five
to ten days just sort of like running
through to finish because there's a I
don't know I wants a decent amount of
stuff to do in these kind of hub worlds
writers like platforming and you took
the act collectibles anyway yeah the
first half of story hours easily yeah
absolutely so how does it feel on the
switch with you guys well we can talk
about handheld but how does it feel on
like Rob I saw you using the pro
controller yeah that's are using the
base I regret not trying out the the
handheld beaky I just use the pro
controller and it felt great but it's
got it was you know the handheld is
tricky I think with like first not first
person but like any kind of like aiming
specific like you think about Selda like
where I would always get frustrated
handhold is whenever I'm aiming down a
bow Randy like that where it's like
fine-tuning like a crosshair so I wonder
if this because you know this game is
very heavily reliant on shooting and
aiming and so I wonder like if how that
feels of you have any problems with it I
don't I I actually I normally don't
really like motion controls I think they
feel really really good in this game so
I've been playing with motion motion
aiming on I played it in a handheld with
the pro controller and with the like the
charging grip um and I like how it works
I think it I think without it
I think the aiming can be a little
clunky in splatoon and this is the case
for the previous game as well but like
the feedback what's the call look the
vibration in the joy comes the rumble HD
Rumble thank you that feels really good
I've noticed that in several switch
games so far and so I really appreciate
that about the switch in general but I
do think the motion like I would suggest
trying motion control it takes a little
bit to get used to but I also did that
with Zelda with the bow motion aiming as
well
Joey was using motion yeah I think it
really
increases your speed and effectiveness
of the weapon especially in splitting
because you're going to be doing a lot
of moving and shooting in conjunction
and because the movement is so weird and
you're like going under the ink it
really helps to streamline that process
I think is what makes it work in
splatoon so I would suggest trying that
if you're like as a Tintin's
on motion controls for sure from your
impressions so far people are asking we
actually do have a Twitter question
that's kind of reflects this so Matt of
the wild otherwise known as Bo cobbling
guts on Twitter was saying do the little
tweaks in splatoon make it a substantial
sequel so this is something that we were
wondering I think maybe it stems from
the fact that when we first saw that
trailer during that initial Nintendo
switch direct we thought it was just
gonna be splatoon deluxe kind of like
what they did with Mario Kart um does
this feel so far like a substantial
sequel I think we're a lot of things you
touched on and make it sound like it is
but I think a lot of people were kind of
wondering that yeah I think it's tricky
I think I need to have more experience I
mean any experience with the multiplayer
to to really say definitively I think
like the so far for the third first
three worlds at least the single-player
feels like it could have been an upgrade
like with Mario Kart 8 deluxe where they
upgraded battle mode it wasn't a sequel
Mario Kart it was just we fixed this one
mode that was underdeveloped that's sort
of my first impression of multiplayer of
single-player was and since I've gotten
furthering it like around the third
world I started to feel like it was even
more substantial than that it does
follow like a and I think the story is
like two years later if you care about
splatoon lore at all which some people
do and love sorry there's no super dark
kind of like one crafting it's extremely
dark like humanity's wiped out the
Inklings are extremely racist against
octolings the octolings
the octolings inhabit the ruins of human
civilization and the Inklings have their
own like their own civilization so a lot
of the levels you see are in like
octoling ruins like human ruins there's
cars now there's cars in this game that
I was like I've never seen cars in
splatoon before which doesn't make it a
substantial sequel but
full of pink in the car you can ink up
the car yeah yeah I mean there's there's
definitely a lot there I think the the
weapon tweaks are also more substantial
than they seem on the surface especially
again I can't know this until I try
multiplayer but like I think your
strategy is going to shift if you played
a lot of multiplayer based on the small
tweaks like the charger is more
threatening in some ways the Dooleys are
a new weapon adds a lot of movement you
can kind of do a dodge roll with the
Dooleys so with that in mind I think
once we play a little more multiplayer
I'll have a better answer for that but
it seems like there's like the there's a
multitude of small changes that actually
make a big impact from what I've seen to
use blue tune lingo it feels fresh I
[Music]
maybe it was because like after hearing
you talk about it I think because during
that Nintendo Direct the things they
chose to focus on we're like oh you
could do a wield weapons now right it
seemed like they focused on these really
minut things and maybe that's why if you
think about that in the context of a
game like splatoon which is so kind of
innovative and different in its own
right those little changes play out in
ways you probably share yeah it's such a
mechanic heavy game or maybe it's
because the mechanics are so kind of
novel yeah for that genre especially
right so it's still it still feels fresh
again to say put it that way sure they
have a new the new like so the hosts are
like Callie and Marie right which is
really weird I've never I never
encounter any other Callie's I'm sure
well but they have new ones
and they say it's like stay off the hook
or something just got the whole calimary
thing like yesterday calamari
yes I just wait I got it now it's also
been tweeting about I was like ah like
yeah everything you just figured out
recently what was the other thing there
was something oh yeah oh man what was it
I don't know I'll think of it while
you're talking about splatoon - I don't
want to derail it completely but I sorry
have you played much multiple area or
have they not even open like sir that
hasn't been open yet gotcha
okay cool and that'll be what in a day
or two maybe that's
beta's like the developers hosting stuff
the reviewers right earlier yeah there's
like early stuff but there's a global
like open one on I think Saturday okay
oh it was the Beatles I didn't I didn't
get the Beatles pun yeah you got flight
of the conchords yeah you know I got
that but I don't I didn't wait what does
this light a Concorde one I'm just
kidding yes but no I'm but The Beatles
went took me a while to get but that
wasn't recently that was like five years
ago still a long time so spittoon two so
far from what you played feels like a
sequel and it's weird to even like level
that question at this game cuz you could
say that about a lot of sequels fed it
really interesting conversations
recently with developers saying making a
sequel is harder than making an original
game at least like trying to please
people but also not stray too far seems
like this is doing a good job so far
yeah I mean it's it's I think it's hard
to make a sequel for something that
isn't like super plot base right because
when you make a sequel to something with
a plot you're just continuing the plot I
think a sequel to something that's all
mechanics is a little harder and I think
they've done a good job at iterating
upon those unique novel mechanics that
we talked about cool
and the question the roller that the
roller weapon why I what's like the game
mode I never played the first one to the
multiplayer mode where it's like you
know team deathmatch or for turf war
yeah so that obviously has use there but
like in the single-player is a good
weapon yeah yeah yeah so I mean you you
can sorta like short it's like a like a
short shotgun blast if you will but you
were talking about making lanes with the
Blazer with I mean that's what you do
with the roller and yeah and you move
faster as you move yes just ramp up on
there yeah I think they kind of buffed
the roller a little bit because the
longer you're actually rolling on the
ground creating ink the faster you go
which is again a good escape tactic
because the squid when you're a kid and
not a squid you're very slow unless you
have like speed up clothes or whatever
what you don't have access to in
single-player
but they also changed it so before it
just kind of did like this wide spray
when you swung it but they changed it so
if you jump
then swing it it does kind of like a
vertical spray which increases your
mobility vertically so they did upgrade
it to kind of have more versatility I
think and then you could get that speed
yeah yeah by by doing that move yeah and
so much of a solution especially
multiplayer obviously is working with
the team right so like you will have a
roller who is serving a practical
purpose not one who is trying to take
people out yeah your roller is probably
going to be doing more of the inking in
turf war than fighting but if you roll
up on someone with a roller and you roll
over them they're basically dead they're
dead
yes roll up on someone do you mean to do
that yeah I will also correct me if I'm
wrong there's gonna be voice chat with
this one now yeah but not the first game
use a different service it's you have to
like buy this weird adapter for your
phone it's dumb it's not through the
game itself I'm so frustrated because
that was the biggest thing missing for
me in splatoon the original splatoon was
this is a team-based thing if you're
gonna like you can't have three rollers
on your team like you're not gonna do
well you need to be able to coordinate
and so I hate that there's this
complicated workaround I will give it a
shot yeah but you won't be able to not
before the review comes out like it
comes out like the launch day or
something [ __ ] rip so on all another
promising entry fee Nintendo switch
right I mean I'm Mario Plus rabbits
coming out August 29th what else am I
missing the rest of the year Mario
Odyssey Mario Odyssey October 27 I want
to talk about October 20 and you know is
it Xenoblade Chronicles two rightful
sequel like with ex the remaster remake
ex was a different game it was like a
let's introduce max let's take this bow
yeah you know series sort of started
with cool there's a lot to get I think
this is my fourth switch review now so
yeah you did with snipper clips
no I did no Matt I did Mario Cart arms
tumble seed and this I love my switch
and I wish I could play everything on it
and some very excited that there's just
tons more coming out for it yeah cool
I'm excited first Platoon to that comes
out July 21st
next fry a week from Friday yeah 20th or
21st
yeah linking cool but yeah those are
single player impressions
we have like written stuff up on the
site if you wanna go look at that we'll
talk more about it next Wednesday a
lobby but Cal yurov you'll be up Tuesday
what time do you know offhand 8 a.m.
Pacific if you want to get more in depth
throughout the whole game after she
plays much more multiplayer over the
weekend cool
speaking of October 27 mario odyssey was
actually kind of funny I was telling you
polygons put up like a Survival Guide
for that day because it's Mario Odyssey
Assassin's Creed origins Wolfenstein -
the new stranger things season that new
weird Cloverfield movie probably yeah
really yeah at this point we haven't
seen anything but did we see much for 10
Cloverfield Lane they got delayed oh
good point I did - I love that movie
nothing to do with the JJ Abrams right
to do a trilogy liar aside from JJ
Abrams right I don't think anything but
the more you look I want to talk about
that movie because I it's super spoiler
heavy no one knows what that movie is
right I was reading a variety article
this morning there it's a series of
movies they're connected interesting ok
um but yeah October 27th actually I want
to get your take what game we're gonna
play first out of those three I have a
strategy figured out ok well let's hear
yours first meet me first ok Wolfenstein
to do that right away no because that
because you can just plow through that
it's gonna be great I hope it's gonna be
great and I like shooter so that's my
first priority I also feel like that
might be the most because of how short
is I might avoid spoilers if I just get
through it and then I think Assassin's
Creed first time I'm excited about
statins Creed and also I think Mario
Odyssey is gonna be I could play it a
year after it comes out it'll still be
fantastic it's not really gonna be
spoiled for me I'm gonna see a lot of it
and it's gonna be just as fun I'll play
that I think third or at least like
Assassin's Creed Mario simultaneously
Mario or Assassins Creed for me I'm more
excited for Mario but I think a Sastry
just seems more I don't know not timely
but I don't know like III can go back to
the Mario 64 it I'd still have fun of it
or a Mario Galaxy and still have fun of
it I mean you know I guess that's fair
you're not gonna get Mario spoiled for
you the same way you would get
Wolfenstein spoiled for you yeah crazy
cliffhanger
Mario kidnapped fouls
wait why Kelly what's your order um I
think all else equal like if I have if I
don't have like early access via the
games industry I would do
Wolfenstein first then based on my
excitement probably Mario and mmm and
then probably Assassin's Creed I am
excited for that game yeah I do want to
note that I'm coming at that says
someone who has privileged enough to
have access to all three of these on the
same day if I had to just buy one
because that's if I didn't have $180 on
I'll get a Wolfenstein oh yeah if I
could only buy one I would say out with
Wolfenstein for the like for the same
reasons I mean that is gonna be there's
many stories spoilers really quickly
yeah I love shooters I am a little bit
of a fangirl for like it'd suck classic
in software yeah Bethesda stuff so like
I would that's a day one purchase for me
I go Mario did okay it was fun to you
that game is that's the only demo I had
aside from like our stage stuff that's
the only demo I had 83 I made sure I can
play that the week after like I can I
could beat Wolfenstein and then play
that and still it would be as fantastic
if it I mean like this isn't it assuming
it's gonna be good but it would be as
good maybe it's day one maybe it's
because I'm like the least curious about
that cuz I already kind of feel like I
get like 96 of it and I'm curious to see
how it unfolds throughout a whole game
and how those sandbox levels will
function but I'm more curious about
Assassin's Creed and Wolfenstein - yeah
I think Wolfenstein I still feel like I
you know what you're getting into
like Mario is just so freaking bizarre
and there was also something so awesome
about like doing a long jump and a
triple jump like haven't been obsessed
with 64 going up like man it's it
maintained that those controls from
she's like think about Zelda think I
know just TN back we were by that game
if you know I mean he just stopped
playing zall those are the things sorry
who really oversaw that team is he did
he wasn't like a producer a director on
the game he oversaw the development of
it he's also overseen the development of
Odyssey and that it already has proven
itself to be different and interesting
enough the way Zelda did when it stood
out when we played it for an hour at e3
and that and my expectations were
nowhere near what an amazing game I got
out of Zelda I just feel like Mario is
going to be this surprising awesome
thing I don't care about Assassin's
Creed unfortunately but Wolfenstein I
want to play but yeah it's like it's
like I okay yeah I can sort of see
what's coming in a sense that I don't
care about the story maybe for me it's
the art it's the spectacle it's the
action Mario is just like the mechanics
kind of yeah yeah a little bit we were
playing we're like remember like and I
was playing the what was the name of
that not that new dog city but whatever
desert desert one if you like go
underneath and there was like that that
like Sphinx dog you could like ride oh
yeah you know what's his name relaxi
right but Jack see Jackie yeah that was
a very obscure surprise like how you got
to it and it was this real fun minigame
where like there's like sandbox levels
now which is kind of messing with the
structure of the traditional 3d Mario
games right I mean Michalak see did it
with like spherical levels and also but
I'm actually looking forward to seeing
how you can kind of tackle these and get
collectables in a different you know
like order I guess yeah that yeah I
guess for me it's like I like Mario I
don't have the same attachment to Mario
that the way I do like Zelda so I think
that's what pushes it back for me also
like not that I'm not excited for that
game and I liked when I played but I
just don't have the same like love for
it and I that's just I don't know I had
a Genesis and so like the n64 was my
first Nintendo console so I don't know
if that has anything to do with it but
yeah Assassin's Creed is after Mario for
me though yeah I am curious where that
came to it was toast arena town by the
way cool so that's pretty much a show
people in the chat have already seen it
because
Chifa to tweet it out but our giveaway
this week is uh pretty cool it's the
storm but storm blood ps4 special
edition for a final fantasy xiv comes a
lot of stuff it's kind of all right i'm
gonna butcher this so bad Zeno's yeah
Galvis figure that's it thanks Rob
storm bought art book cloth map of a or
Xia sure
logo sticker kind of there you're in the
center an exclusive in-game items
soldier mount wind up Bart's minion and
chicken knife so Chennai sounds useful
and tasty that out so follow game spawn
on Twitter if you don't retweet that
later on the week I think usually around
Thursday will pick a random winner will
send it to your house if you're in the
US apologies people outside of that
specific territory cool so that's our
show as always thank you to people in
the background loop psyche Richard Lee
Eric Tay for producing the show thank
you all for joining me
we'll be back next time Wednesday 11:00
a.m. Pacific as always see you guys then
[Music]